good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my word is believed and
I believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's problems today's
message is don't care what others think
over to you Warren Buffett it never
bothered me if people disagreed with
what I thought as long as I thought
under the facts I mean there's a whole
bunch of things I don't know think about
I just stay away from those so I stay
within what I call my circle of
competence you know that Tom Watson said
it best he said you know he said he said
I'm no genius but I'm smart in spots and
I stay around those spots well I try and
stay around those spots and I I just
don't have a problem if somebody says
you know you're wrong on something I'd
go back and look at the facts and I
think that I think that really is much
more important frankly than having a few
points of IQ or or having an extra
course or two in school or anything of
the sort you need emotional stability I
really love that last bit to be talked
about emotional stability I think it's
really important for entrepreneurs to
understand where your threshold is of
how much crap you could take from other
people how much negativity how much
feedback and criticism that you could
take without it impacting your psyche or
your self-worth I think in general as an
entrepreneur you need to be prepared to
get a lot of crap a lot of negativity a
lot of stuff thrown at you and yes it's
easy to say don't care what other people
think but understanding what your
tolerance level is and where you kind of
fit on that spectrum can really help you
design the rules so that they're in your
favor so as an example there's a guy on
my team who doesn't handle criticism as
well you know I'm a lot more comfortable
in the uncomfortable where he can bounce
around a lot more of who on top of the
world like this is great and then
negative feedback comes in and it really
impacts them hardly and then the
positive one comes in any jokes back up
and so for someone like him you can't
design as much risk as much a negativity
or potential negativity so you got to
take
a safe path up where for me I'm more
comfortable in the uncomfortable I know
that eventually something's going to
work out and I know that at the
beginning of any project it's going to
be rough that it made a hut workout then
we're going to get some criticism and so
I'm more willing to jump all in and play
in that field even though it's painful
at the moment because I know the faster
I get to that pain the fast we're going
to come out the other side I want that
feedback and criticism negativity as
soon as possible so that I can make it
better better for you better for me
better for everybody and so
understanding what your tolerance level
is of emotional stability how much you
can take from your friends and your
family and your customers and your
audience and the people watching you
before you break and then be able to
play just below that limit because you
can't just play super safe because
that's not going to make you happy as an
entrepreneur but no one your limit isn't
playing just below it so that it's
uncomfortable it's painful but you're
still going to be able to get through it
I think is really important that
self-awareness I think is really
important as an entrepreneur so the
question day today is I'm curious how
high is your tolerance level for taking
criticism for other people how much does
it bother you and can you get through it
or not really curious to find out please
leave it down in the comments below I
also want to give a quick China to
leaflet Lian Wheatland thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word I really really appreciate the
support and I hope you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
Press
for this recipe we go
if the rest of the people really feel
they meet as a politician furthermore
bad politicians and I feel sad or
cunning great cunning liar politicians
then of course no problem
the one son says I'm the good person
sons a bad person and dull matter some
of my own motivation for thinking is
honest since a that's it that's
important that's simple Buddhist monks
actually easy but that is it taught
don't care for the others are the same
if one say too much praise then at that
time should think oh I also have the
critics and then one says it one
criticism then you should think or some
people pissing me the so doesn't matter
too much so because of the pay much
attention these things are silly how did
you ignore all those naysayers and
continue to sort of blaze the trail
about 90 95 % of all new ventures fail
so if you just bet against all new
ventures the odds or 90% you're going to
be right 90% of the time but you're
going to miss that one out of 110 or 120
chances to to really hit a home run and
I wasn't worried about Dom then they say
are saying it wasn't going to work I
just I just laughed about it because I
knew it was and you worked very hard at
it is well I I wasn't going to let it
fail and even if you read my book it's
right there that I wasn't going to let
it fail and I'm not going to let all I'm
not going to let humanity fail to get
rid of nuclear weapons and and now and
and and and handle this energy thing I'm
going to keep fighting till till we
start getting it right pay a lot
attention to reviews and those kind of
things well you know you're always
affected by opinion but the
the more opinions there are of you the
more I the less I look at them because I
just can't live my life based upon what
other people think about me so I can't
concern myself too much with what other
people think you know it's just not
healthy I don't think I can I could
continue to do what I do if I was
constantly worrying about what somebody
thought about it